bullet head podcast go watch the full
interview with this guy a little seat
though out right now
uh we're about to have him rap this is
what he came to do so let's get to it
man let's get it huh
i made a way for all my people now it's
time for him to follow up i never duck
[ __ ] we could shoot him we can squabble
up i like to stay aware so i hardly pick
a bottle up i don't really vent i just
keep my feelings bottled up
[Music]
i had nobody stay till the end of the
ride everybody seems to go in and least
me alive and i was rocking for you heavy
you decided to lie i was spinning blow
by your name and i was ready to die
burberry on my feed maca mary on my
jeans you be beefing with that [ __ ] you
can't be her on my team broad day
busting i don't need to flash the beam
tool seven get to bark and put a space
up on the screen i'm like real active
real tragic get it cracking i ain't
never been a [ __ ] and when i say it i
ain't acting i ain't never on no broke
[ __ ] rapping doesn't work and get my
[ __ ] to bring the loafing i saw me
frozen if it's money on a flow then you
got my attention one in the head 30 up
in this extension bad kid but i never
got detention bring the beef to my feet
we don't entertain dimension
253 baby no cap the new album it's out
on all platforms rapping at 16 year old
what tune in
let's go hey i know you just watched a
brand new freestyle presented to you by
our good folks at lrg don't forget if
you go to lrg right now the website will
be right there broom l dash r dash g.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get 30 percent off your order that's l
dash r dash g.com you'll see it right
down there
save 30 off your order by putting in
that promo code bootleg and shout out to
lrg we got another freestyle coming next
week